je n'ai pas l'habitude de parler son
stand un fil isolé et aussi sans guitare
ça non plus mesdames et messieurs j'ai
faim alors j'essaye de faire ça très
court je vous présente ma part d'un
système j'ai deux assistants qui sont
ici en singine nous embête fondante et
mesdames messieurs perdre
radio-canada stafford est très analogue
aujourd'hui je n'avais pas le temps de
me préparer ça va juste qu'une heure
pour préparer
nicolas l'autre assistant romont alors
il faut juste que tenir bien morte assez
joli pont un pur linguistique français
allemand bilingue bilingue je vous
présente quelques mots sahara event
mania d'art moderne
diffusion interdite soumis un crime
surtout les welches il faut que vous
vous gardez ça dans la terre hockey
premièrement c'est ça
à paris répétez à paris c'est une fraise
hockey une fraise ok ça reste dans ma
tête à paris deuxièmement c'est une
chaîne et a répété non jeunes étant
celles du singe in motion et à l'état
c'est une tartine hockey à peu riche des
tartines de frais cependant d'autres
risques répéter ce père round earth
risque bien centre good cpournous crise
il ya deux mois maintenant apprendre
qu'un hymne yard
encore une fois c'est pas très bien m il
ya pendant une année
1 dans une année il ya deux mots ma à
l'école mon fils il a promis que les
écoles de écoles primaires et puis il
doit prendre ch lui doit aussi apprendre
l'allemand
chc hockey marc est répétée hockey fait
fait
c'est rouge passant d'un peu bizarre
pour le belge n'existe pas un mais on
peut vous dire route une fois rod aurait
les oreilles nasa s'est pas rasé nazaire
bernois aussi chez nous on dit nasa bon
ok on n'a pas des pages sur la lune avec
un âne nasa c'est le nez un arbre c'est
les cheveux
ok maintenant il ya neuf cassine nos
cordes op den bos au crime violent c'est
un vote bloqué
c'est une verte à l'asie ce crâne scène
verte hockey à paris i steiner fraises
chine et à ce jour notre risque 730 your
de pendant une année un marc faye roth
rouge oreilles aurora hockey vous pouvez
laisser tomber une fois appris ce faire
pour nicolas et béate
josy france quittera la guitare a
précisé que cette vente par le staff des
composites musiques d'afrique non si
jeune et en hockey c'est une chanson en
dialecte est ce que vous comprenez cette
chanson à un peu riche en état le matin
et le soir à un peu riche n'est à ce
point de tri ce qu'ignore martron six
autres continents cents ou un peu rire
aussi à une chanson au fond que j'écris
assez connu dans saint gilles poux sur
un peu dans toute la suisse ou est ce
que vous comprenez vous comprenez ce que
je dis à un peu riche en état le matin
et le soir à un peu riche n'étant
cependant deux prises quignard mar 30 y
aura un continent où un peu rires on
tire
ok vous a compris l'histoire aussi sur
121 x tra bi en vigueur est d'abord un
troc cuisine j'ai vu un truc sur le t
rex de l'université lynn puis le mec qui
s'appelait crise lance t il faut que
vous allez regarder mais seulement last
song est ce que tu as romain éphrem tu
feras retour à prendre une deuxième
langue
ok et puis il dit 1 c'est pas seulement
lui qui dit ça parce qu'une recherche
mondialement avec 200 c'est très
analogue en vous voyez le feutre noir il
déjà j'avais plus il valait plus et
maintenant bleus 250 mo 126 votes mais
mendy gran si vous savez 250 mans vous
arrivez de parler de faire une phrase
d'un égal dans quelle langue
on parle plutôt longue européen mais ok
250 mo avec 750 mans on arrive de parler
ensemble
vous pouvez aller à berlin hambourg et
munich ou à berne ou à tavel si vous
voulez on arrive de parler ensemble avec
750 mots n'arrivent de parler bien sûr
pas très profonde comme connectique
natif avec ok c'est 150 mans je garde ça
un peu près chez moi mais tu y vas y tu
fais une faveur
on parle déjà très bien la crainte jones
--le comité 2500 vous arrivez bien parlé
ensemble
ok on parle de 5000 noms et plus ça
c'est la langue maternelle a zoo pour
des gens peut-être pas très éduqués ou
pas très habile de dia mais 5000
non on arrive ça c'est notre langue
maternelle on termine ce soir
bien sûr il ya des gens qui sont
beaucoup plus ce mot dans la dette comme
moi mais dans ce match par alors
renouvelé alors et puis moi je me suis
demandée on habite à fribourg 1
mais on est tout près un mois je fais un
kilomètre je suis je parle plus français
parallèlement je me suis dit comment
c'est pas possible parce que il faut
apprendre 750 mo ça veut dire
dimon on a appris dit mon maintenant en
singine ouah ça peut être aussi chinois
si vous voulez un saint génois dimon
dans dix minutes
alors si je vous donne ce devoir dit
monde en un jour dans 75 jours vous
arrivez parlé ensemble
ok alors dans ce 1 5 6 semaines on
arrive de par l'ensemble même si vous
êtes un chinois où je sais pas où vous
par les nôtres mais nous on habite tout
près un franc français allemand 750
montez un creux trouve pas c'est
vraiment dingue 700 et on arrive de
parler ensemble alors dans ses
recherches et visera une dixième
recherche 12e qu'edouard talons il le
sait le talent c'est égal de talent on
s'en fout le talent vous pouvez être
vraiment stupide où pouvez-vous talence
est égal à 2 canal flou ça c'est pas de
france pour apprendre une langue
mais fo fait qu il faut avoir le courage
de faire des erreurs
moi j'étais un devoir nicolas bideau ici
mais on est aussi invitée en cas carte à
hemani il n'y a pas de longtemps aussi
présent ce fils qui nous avons invité et
moi j'ai billets ou aux étudiants sur
place il ya une grande faculté français
à jakarta je dirais ouakam et leur côté
de mon père me disait mais moi je fais
des erreurs tout le monde a rigolé combo
or il faut faire les erreurs mais dans
monsieur moi j'ai un trois et demi dans
mon humanité crise comme des carnets
écoles machin truc mais ce qu'on dit aux
français voilà trois et demi et moi j'ai
un prix de la du bilinguisme du canton
fribourg madame mais c'est ok ok et faut
faire faire des erreurs mais je sais à
peu riche notation c'est un peu bizarre
astronomique rom et gens de sainte
un mot sur un gouvernement au service
canada furie intestines je me suis pas
du tout intéressé les français mais d'un
monsieur pas du tout juste que je fais
la connaissance avec céline
céline elle parlait que français safran
serait moi j'ai appris dans deux trois
semaines je pouvais parler avec elle ok
peut-être avec seulement 29
mais j'arrive je parle avec elle
messaoud ce bizarre moi je vais dans des
écoles germanophone et puis j'apprends
une chanson en français
depuis lundi je fais le contraire
bientôt dans les écoles roman alors et
j'attends une chanson en allemand juste
pour pour qu'ils ont pris plaisir et
puis entendre l'allemand s'est pas si
nuls voyez afribo ses proches le
allemand france aime quand je vais à
lausanne ils ont rien à
non monsieur désolé je ne rigole pas
lausanne et puis je n'évoque au pire
alors ils ont rien à du elles
m'ont pas ce que ça sente pas bien ils
n'en ont pas la musique un peu et qu'on
désire rien tandis qu'en je vais
berne/zurich ça va encore mais quand je
vais à tour de vis sans gaza sans nous
c'est bizarre le français mais parce
qu'ils n'ont pas l'habitude comme nous
mais nous c'est important je trouve à
fribourg alors descendre il faut on peut
écouter un peu comment ça semble un peu
riche et a commencé son de bénédiction
c'est un peu et après parler c'est un
training mais d'un monsieur c'est un
training il faut toujours le faire on
peut chercher vous un bon copain en
suisse allemand comme moi moi je fais un
training avec vous et vous apprenez le
vocabulaire passive le beaucoup plus
vite que active alors vous arrivez de
peut-être comprendre 750 mo et pas
parler avec moi
facile training et à la fin et puis ça
je trouve dans cette étude d'acheter ou
de vendre en baisse
la clé pour apprendre une autre langue
c'est pas ce mot longue aussi la culture
c'est de nous aimer les murs nous
abaisserons de lillebonne et puis c'est
pas seulement aimer quelqu'un d'autre
c'est aussi à voir l'intérêt à quelqu'un
d'autre vous aurez une tracy fonction
religieuse presque parce que moi
j'apprends ça depuis 20 ans je chante on
sait de longue et puis la seule chose
que moi j'ai fait à mon début de gunma
bhp grade
la seule chose que j'ai fait j'ai je
trouvais une fille très belle je voulais
je voulais apprendre c'est longue
parce que je voulais parler avec elle et
pas seulement ouais alors alors c'était
la clé jusqu'à voir l'intérêt à
quelqu'un d'autre
j'ai encore dix minutes pose pourquoi
c'est fini c'est vrai on doit une
chanson moi j'ai fini mais merci bien